me
kei
Why did I have to buy it? The cuts are now cutters ah
ah ah
[music]
What are you
ah ah ah muddy ah ah ah
nani
[music]
Natafuuuu
re too
This guy is the leader
Yeah,
this is the rider
Kahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh  It's the top of the early morning
Take off f Wow ah ah ah
yes ah
ah ah ah
ah ah
ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah
ah  There was a doctor's thing, but for the time being, Hideki Matsui
Hyper, I
'm afraid you're dead, so I
do
n't think you
're going
crazy.  Chan ni
ha
ran
[laughs]
Higher
[music]
Hahn included,
etc.
t
Charlie
[applause]
Hina-chan sorry
entered
[music]
ni
car
tre
[music]
ana
car
rar This company is a good example of Hina-chan.
Resent
ah ah ah